bienvenue nous sommes en direct ce lundi
après-midi 16h pour faire un nouveau
point de situation sur l'Ukraine puisque
les choses ont beaucoup bougé
aujourd'hui et pour cela je suis avec
Alexis ferchak bonjour Alexis bonjour
Vincent les journalistes et adjo
paulactu avec vous on va revenir sur ce
qui s'est passé ce matin toutes les
décisions qui ont été prises pourquoi
est-ce qu'il y a eu des nouvelles
frappes des tout au long de soleil vous
les internautes vous n'hésitez pas comme
d'habitude à poser vos questions on y
répond au mieux on va quand même
commencer par dire ce qui s'est passé ce
matin des frappes de multiples frappes
sur beaucoup d'endroits de l'Ukraine oui
alors en résumé il y a eu des frappes
russes il y a eu des tirs de vibrant 75
missiles russes qui ont été tirés
effectivement de l'Ouest jusqu'à l'est
de l'Ukraine vous voyez tout à l'ouest
si la ville de Le Vif Kiev a été
massivement touché ce matin avec des
plusieurs points d'impact dans la dans
la capitale ukrainienne également dans
l'Est n'apparaît pas sur la carte mais à
carquef qui est vraiment dans l'est de
dernière semaine
qui ont été plutôt victorieuses et même
très clairement victorieuses et on ne
sait pas tellement la question
aujourd'hui principale c'est comment
est-ce que le le Kremlin peut réagir à
court moyen et long terme pour inverser
la tendance et si vous voulez c'est 75
missiles c'est une première réponse de
l'avenir Poutine on verra que c'est une
réponse politique forte une réponse
symbolique forte et d'ailleurs toute la
droite de Poutine qui est importante la
droite nationaliste était extrêmement
contente mais militairement on va voir
que que c'est loin d'apporter une
solution à la Russie et ça c'est
vraiment l'enjeu d'aujourd'hui c'est que
peuvent faire les Russes
face au changement de dynamique
aujourd'hui c'est les Ukrainiens qu'on
l'avantage
il faut qu'il trouve un moyen de les
faire reculer je salue Anafi qui nous
rejoint Joe COS Anafi qui nous pose déjà
la question alors on va peut-être la
poser maintenant qui demande si les
Russes envoient une ogive nucléaire
tactique
est-ce que tout de suite parler du
nucléaire sinon ce qui est intéressant
c'est que le Kremlin devant le les
journalistes qui étaient réunis pour
pour l'occasion ce matin on
redit qu'il n'y avait pas que le
l'épisode du pont de Crimée n'impliquait
pas une utilisation du nucléaire par la
Russie on en avait déjà parlé tous les
deux je me je me souviens la doctrine
nucléaire russe elle est relativement
floue il y a un flou quelque part il y a
quelle liste les circonstances dans
lesquelles la Russie peut utiliser
l'arme nucléaire les trois premières
catégories sont extrêmement classiques
c'est un missile balistique une arme
nucléaire une arme de destruction
massive une arme pas forcément nucléaire
mais qui toucherait les infrastructures
vitales de
l'État russe on peut imaginer le Kremlin
ou etc et puis la quatrième
circonstance dans laquelle l'arme
nucléaire peut être employée c'est si
jamais l'existence de l'Etat russe est
mise en danger et c'est là où cette
formule peut être on va dire interpréter
de manière minimaliste ou maximaliste on
ne peut pas dire que l'effondrement du
pont Crimée
menace l'existence de l'utérus en
revanche c'est vrai que ça pour le coup
c'est vraiment un lieu absolument
stratégique pour les Russes là on voit
la carte donc ça sera plus simple si
vous voulez les Russes cohésion la
Crimée en 2014
au-delà plus au nord c'est l'Ukraine et
donc depuis 2014 la la Crimée en fait
était coupée du territoire russe et donc
Poutine un peu en catastrophe a fait
construire ce pont qui a été mis en
service il y a deux ans si je n'abuse
qui a un pont à la fois routier
ferroviaire et là la partie ferroviaire
refonctionne de nouveau et la portion
routière également en partie donc si
vous voulez le pont n'a pas été
construit il était juste abîmé on
reviendra sur le comment ça a été fait
mais bref c'est un point d'accès vital
pour la Crimée et ce qu'on fait les
russes depuis le 24 février c'est depuis
le début de l'opération militaire
spéciale c'était conquérir un corridor
terrestre qui va de la Crimée jusqu'au
territoire russe en passant par le
dombasque avait été partiellement annexé
par la panique c'est notre contrôlé par
la Russie dès 2014 et qui aujourd'hui
formellement un excès et donc vous voyez
si vous voulez ça ça permet à la
réussite de rejoindre par la terre la
Crimée sauf qu'avant il y avait quand
même le pont et donc maintenant ça rend
toute cette zone de terre absolument
vitale pour la Russie alors même que
vous avez deux contre-offensives
ukrainiennes
au debout du dispositif rue sa
Carcassonne à l'ouest à carcif au nord
et que par ailleurs quand il est les
réseaux sociaux russes il y a une sorte
de de crainte majeure d'une offensive
ukrainienne le troisième qui partirait
vous voyez la zone centrale qui
s'appelle
zapporigia et là si les Ukrainiens
filaient au sud ils arriveraient vers là
vers la capitale entre guillemets russe
de cette région qui fait le médico-paul
et si les Ukrainiens prenaient militent
Paul bernion etc après avoir tapé le
pont de Crimée la Crimée se retrouve
vraie complètement
bloquée du territoire russe et ça c'est
évidemment à garder à l'esprit sachant
que les Ukrainiens dans leur discours
politique et de plus en plus
il considère que l'objectif n'est pas de
reprendre juste les territoires contre
les depuis le 24 février c'est de
reprendre tous les territoires dans les
frontières de l'Ukraine de 1991 c'est à
dire Crimée crime et comprise toutes ces
territoires assuré finalement parce que
c'est territoire
c'est ses territoires là qui ont été
récupérés
à cette époque en 2014
2014 etc et puis le le moment de
cristallisation ça a été la semaine
dernière comme Vladimir Poutine a
formellement annexer les rattachés
l'ensemble de ces territoires
à la Fédération de Russie sachant
qu'auparavant il y avait que la Crimée
qui était russe endroit russe très bien
alors vous n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions à la fille Machiavel Machiavel
qui nous demande est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
d'accord tacite des puissances
nucléaires est-ce qu'on alors il nous
demande est-ce que nucléaire on revient
encore sur nucléaire il me demande si la
prolifération des armes nucléaires est
relancée avec ce conflit
[Musique]
est plus ancien que la que la crise
ukrainienne on le voit sur un certain
nombre de dossiers évidemment le dossier
nord-coréen puisque la Corée du Nord est
devenue une puissance nucléaire on le
voit avec l'Iran c'est une c'est un
mouvement historique de fragilisation
des grands textes qui encadré la
l'arme nucléaire dans le monde mais
passons sur ce point il y a un doute sur
l'utilisation de de l'arme tactique
alors pourquoi parce qu'encore une fois
les marges de manœuvre de la Russie en
Ukraine on le verra c'est ce qu'il faut
vraiment comprendre aujourd'hui c'est
que les marges de manœuvre de Poutine
elles sont extrêmement faibles il a
déclenché la mobilisation partielle mais
ça me parle de 300 000 hommes sauf que
ça prend plusieurs
mois enfin pour que ça soit vraiment
efficace il faudra plusieurs mois en
attendant qu'est-ce qu'il fait il un
dispositif de 150 à 200 000 hommes dans
l'ensemble de cette zone
donc voilà en hachuré ou en orange face
à lui il y a une armée ukrainienne qui
est beaucoup plus importante à la fois
en quantité en nombre d'hommes il y a
probablement un rapport de 1 à 2 entre
les Russes et les ukrainiens et
localement en rapport beaucoup plus
important parce qu'en plus les
Ukrainiens sont très mobiles voilà et
par ailleurs ils ont donc cette mobilité
qui est plus grande une logistique qui
est facilité parce qu'ils sont dans leur
territoire et que si vous voulez le le
sens de de enfin
l'inclinaison du corridor fait que quand
c'est plus facile de déplacer
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur de ce que
il dort et puis par ailleurs ils ont ces
équipements occidentaux qui sont moins
nombreux que la puissance de Fleurus
mais qui ont un avantage qu'on voit très
clairement aujourd'hui en termes
technologique et qui se traduit sur le
terrain en termes de précision de
rapidité etc surtout associé au
renseignements américains qui fait que
les Ukrainiens sont très bien ont des
résultats tactiques sur le terrain qui
sont qui très bien l'explosion du pont
de Kirch donc est-ce qu'on sait de qui
oui alors il y a eu au début vous savez
le en fait l'explosion a eu lieu au
moment où un train chargé de carburant
passé et qui a expliqué qui explique
notamment le le la taille de la
puissance de l'explosion et puis il y
avait un camion qui qui passait en même
temps au sens opposé alors c'était dit
on s'est dit à un moment que la charge
explosive était dans le camion il
semblerait que ça ne soit pas le cas et
en fait quand on regarde dans la vidéo
il y a une fraction de seconde on voit
que sous le pont on voit une sorte
d'embarcation qui qui passe sous le pont
donc c'est sur l'eau au niveau du
détroit de de kercht et visiblement
c'est le c'est l'hypothèse qui
aujourd'hui quasiment officialisée c'est
en fait une sorte de de petit
embarcation
c'est un drone enfin il y a pas de
pilote c'est tout petit on dirait une
barque ça se voit à peine parce que
c'est très très bas sur l'eau c'est en
partie enfoncée c'est quasiment anti
enfin c'est
submersible et donc c'est un drone en
anglais on appelle ça un USB
et qui était chargé d'explosifs et en ce
qui est intéressant c'est que ce type
d'embarcation les Russes on avait
capturé un il y a quelques semaines
pas très loin de Sébastopol donc
visiblement c'est ce type d'embarcation
qui a été utilisé
par les services secrets
Ukrainiens le SBU avec probablement des
des forces spéciales
ukrainiennes c'est une très belle
opération qui a été menée par les par
les ukrainien
a été rondements mené et en plus un
point intéressant ils ont tapé le pont
le matin il y avait quasiment pas de
civils et ça c'est intéressant du point
de vue d'une droite international parce
que plus précisément du droit des
conflits armés ou du droit international
humanitaire
qui fait que le l'argument russe selon
lequel ce serait une attaque terroriste
contre un lieu civil juridiquement ça
tient pas parce qu'en fait on doit des
conflits armés
on définit pas un bien civil
positivement le définit négativement par
rapport à un bien militaire et donc un
bien qu'on peut croire civil comme un
pont peut être un bien militaire s'il a
une utilité militaire à la fois pour
l'adversaire et pour celui qui qui
l'attaque or là c'est le c'est
évidemment le cas on l'a dit puisque
c'est un nœud logistique absolument
vital pour la pour la Russie surtout la
partie ferroviaire parce que la
logistique russe passe beaucoup par le
chemin de fer et en revanche s'ils ont
respecté par ailleurs un principe de
proportionnalité puisque il n'y avait
pas à ce moment-là de civil et ce qui
est intéressant d'ailleurs c'est qu'on
ne peut probablement pas en dire autant
enfin pour l'instant on a peu d'éléments
donc on va parler conditionnel mais on
peut pas en dire autant des frappes
russes depuis ce matin qui sont
extrêmement impressionnantes il faut
voir qu'en termes de moyens c'est très
au-delà c'est-à-dire que les Russes sont
employés des missiles à longue portée
des missiles de croisière ici quelle
ligne d'émissile balistique
Islander etc c'est des armes chaque arme
coûte un 2 millions de dollars ils sont
capables de frapper très loin ils sont
capables de frapper dans la profondeur
de dans toute la profondeur de de
l'Ukraine ce que les Ukrainiens pour
l'instant ne savent pas faire parce que
les occidentaux se sont toujours refusés
à fournir à l'Ukraine des armements à
longue portée qui pourrait permettre
d'atteindre le territoire russe dans la
profondeur mais quoi qu'il en soit cette
attaque russe extrêmement massive
extrêmement impressionnante quel est son
intérêt militaire et c'est là où on peut
avoir un doute alors ils ont ébranlé le
système électrique
ukrainien c'est indubitable et ça ça va
être un des enjeux majeurs notamment
pour les mois de pendant cet hiver
c'est-à-dire que si les Ukrainiens
se trouvent sans électricité
ça va avoir un impact plus ou moins
grand sur la logistique
comme on le dit qui arrive absolument
donc ça ça aura un impact malgré tout le
l'utilité militaire de ces frappes
apparaît assez faible c'était surtout
des des frappes politiques
symbolique il pouvait pas laisser cette
attaque contre le compte Kirch mais je
vais prendre un exemple vraiment
pratique aux pratiques il y a au moins
un missile qui a touché un pont à Kiev
mais c'est pas un pont sur le enjambant
le nièpre et qui a un intérêt logistique
en l'occurrence c'était un pont piéton
au dessus d'un parc donc c'était une
passerelle et qui d'ailleurs au passage
était tellement fine que évidemment le
missile russe l'a raté donc ici il est
passé en dessous donc ça si vous voulez
ça dit tout à la fois
de la relative imprécision des pour eux
c'est ça on le voit depuis le début de
l'opération militaire spéciale et en
même temps un intérêt militaire assez
frappe qui est relativement limité pour
l'instant et donc se repose la vraie
question qu'est-ce que de manière
pratique de Vladimir Poutine peut faire
pour tenir le terrain il n'a pas le
droit de reculer il a déjà énormément
reculé concrètement il a il a perdu à
Liman il a perdu la coupiance qu'il a
perdu à zium
aujourd'hui donc là c'est on va dire
dans la région de quartier donc c'est
dans le dispositif au nord du dispositif
russe et par ailleurs il est sous
pression à l'ouest du dispositif russe
et il y a une grande ville qui s'appelle
Kerson qui enjambe venir tout team ne
peut pas se permettre de perdre cette
ville de quasiment 300 000 habitants qui
est la seule capitale régionale que la
Russie a contrôlé depuis le 24 février
et qui en plus c'est un de tête de pont
pour passer de l'autre côté du Nieppe
donc là il y a un enjeu militaire
extrêmement important pour Poutine et
c'est pas les frames de ce matin qui
vont résoudre ce problème puisque on en
a d'autres qui demandent est-ce qu'il
est-ce qu'il est vrai que les Russes
reprennent du terrain en Ukraine alors
pour être extrêmement précis disons que
là où les Ukrainiens ont avancé sur
plusieurs de
milliers de kilomètres carrés depuis
le début du mois de septembre les
ukra les Urus n'ont jamais arrêté
d'exercer une pression dans le seul
endroit où ils sont offensive qui est la
ville de backmouth backmouth dans le
blaze de doniak exactement parfait c'est
là j'ai bien retenu mes cours de
géographie ukrainiennes
alors c'est une petite ville de 30 000
habitants ça n'est pas un enjeu
militaire massif les deux grandes villes
à prendre dans dans l'aublast dans la
région de Nieppe c'est carmator c'est la
viande
les Russes sont très loin avant ça il
faut faire tomber la première ligne de
défense ukrainienne qui est composée de
deux villes d'akmouth et sévèrek assez
vertes les rues les Russes reculent donc
qui reviennent vers l'Est les échanges
alors il continue à presser notre maison
très loin de prendre la ville là ils ont
avancé de 2 km à l'ouest et au nord dans
la banlieue de mais ils sont encore très
loin de prendre ce lieu qui est une
place forte fortifiée ukrainienne
peut-être peut-être que dans quelques
semaines mais ils auront avancé 10 km
oui et le risque du coup c'est que il se
retrouve pris en étau par les par la
contre
là mais mais le mais le risque existe si
un effondrement local du dispositif
russe et on a vu que
il y a déjà eu par deux fois dans l'Est
un effondrement
local alors modulo le fait quand même
que à chaque fois les Russes il faut
dire qu'il commence à avoir l'habitude
et que c'est une tradition historique
ils ont réussi à chaque fois pour
l'instant à se replier en bonheur enfin
il se replie en bonheur mais malgré tout
à chaque fois ils sont obligés de
laisser derrière eux des des dizaines de
véhicules de blindés de chars de canon
de des tonnes de munitions et surtout du
surtout du territoire oui effectivement
alors vous vous voyez toujours cette
carte on parlait tout à l'heure il y a
quelque chose qui était intéressant
c'est sur les 75 missiles qui ont été
tirés certains ont été interceptés oui
alors d'après les Ukrainiens donc c'est
apprendre avec énormément de de
pincettes et ils ont annoncé que 41 des
75 missiles avaient été intercepté aux
il est probable que le chiffre de 43
soit un peu exagéré mais
éclore dans les dans les jours à venir
alors
les Allemands ont fourni un système qui
s'appelle le système iris les Finlandais
ont fourni un autre système finlandais
mais avec des missiles américains qui
s'appelle je pas l'écorcher son Asma et
puis il y a pas mal de débats j'ai
remarqué ce matin est-ce que la France
pourrait fournir des
SMT le système
anti-arien longue portée français le
problème c'est que nous on en a très peu
les Allemands les enfin tous les
Européens c'est en matière anti-aérienne
les moyens sont absolument
échantillonnes échantillons de mer
enbrillonnaire parce que toutes les
guerres on a combattu il y avait pas une
très grande menace aérienne donc ça a
été
sous développé ces dernières années
et donc est-ce qu'on peut envoyer
suffisamment d'armements à l'Ukraine
c'est pas c'est pas évident c'est un
très grand territoire à quadrillé et
comme on l'a vu le les armes russes si
on a de différentes sortes les missiles
balistiques islandeur sont difficiles à
intercepter parce qu'ils vont
extrêmement vite et c'est une
trajectoire avec un inclinaison un ongle
qui est très importante et c'est pas une
trajectoire
prédictive je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails mais c'est une trajectoire assez
complexe les missiles de croisière qui
c'est ce sont eux qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à le vif à 2000 2500 km de portée
ce sont des missiles calibres qui sont
tirés depuis des navires en mer Noire et
d'ailleurs ils semblent avec les
missiles calibre
et soit rentré dans les eaux
internationaux enfin dans le au moins
dans les eaux
d'ailleurs ils se sont plains alors ces
missile ils veulent beaucoup beaucoup
plus bas beaucoup moins vite ils sont
plus facile interceptable sauf qu'il
faut quand même pouvoir aller voir parce
que justement ils peuvent voler assez
bas et
enfin il y a les drones et alors les
drones il y a des chaînes 136 Iraniens
qui sont des drones suicides
coins très long rayon d'action
pardon je m'étouffe
[Musique]
et voilà qui sont très difficiles à
t'insulter parce qu'ils sont tout petits
tout petits effectivement on a pas mal
de questions on va essayer de répondre à
tout le monde bien évidemment on a
Machiavel qui nous demande si une
nouvelle offensive à l'est de confiance
qui réussit est-ce que la logistique
russe notamment vers le dombasme ne
serait pas compromise si c'est tout
l'enjeu c'est tout l'enjeu d'où les
la réflexion des Russes sur comment
frapper le dispositif ukrainien dans la
profondeur oui en fait tout l'enjeu
c'est de d'assécher la logistique
finalement absolument pour pour le
bloquer gringo combien de temps
l'Ukraine pour assouvir sa mobilisation
générale et quand est-ce que la Russie
commencera sa propre mobilité en général
c'est encore un levier pour Poutine ça
c'est une question de semaine et une
question de de moi et le temps est et à
la fois court pour la Russie est long
c'est-à-dire la menace c'est à court
terme et les mobilisés n'interviendront
massivement que dans que dans deux trois
mois effectivement on a une autre
question sur je vais essayer de la
retrouver Louise qui nous demande les
habitants de la Crimée est-ce que on
sait s'il voit ce qui se passe
du côté en fait est-ce qu'il voit les
combats est-ce qu'il soutiennent la
réussite est-ce que les proscriens sont
déjà partis est-ce qu'on sait ce qui se
passe là-bas sur place en Crimée
elle sait qu'il y a eu il y avait pas
mal de départ de population à un moment
enfin il y a pas de panique générale et
d'ailleurs c'est une question politique
qui est très délicate c'est que
quand même il semble quand même que les
criméens depuis 2014 c'était quand même
plutôt
favorable à l'idée de rentrer dans la
Russie enfin il y a
même l'ambiance n'est pas la même
d'ailleurs que que dans le reste de
l'Ukraine et donc maintenant si les
Ukrainiens reprenait la Crimée ça peut
soit une vraie question est-ce que ça
serait une est-ce que vous parlerait de
libération je suis pas sûr que la
population criméenne je sois extrêmement
content de content de retourner
le fait qu'il y aurait des des combats
et que finalement la Crimée il y a pas
une guerre la Crimée a été épargné par
la guerre contrairement au nombas parce
que je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
mais quand il y a eu l'annexion
en 2014 il y a eu les petits hommes
verts de petites mais ils sont pas
battus
peut-être essayer d'aller chercher un
petit verre d'eau après tout à l'heure
quand même ça pourrait aider alors
j'avais une autre question oui parce que
on parlait de des ressorts possibles et
on a eu une annonce du côté de la
Biélorussie aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé alors déjà est-ce qu'on peut
rappeler un peu la Biélorussie c'est
quand même ils sont liés à Poutine
historiquement le le dictateur qui qui
dirige la Biélorussie depuis 80
peut-être pas 91 enfin dans ces eaux là
je veux pas dire de bêtises peut-être 95
je crois
il était extrêmement attaché
à son sa relative indépendance par
rapport à Poutine et donc dans les liens
les liens entre la Russie la Biélorussie
était un peu ambiguë c'était à la fois
très proche et en même temps
Lucas and Co des Poutine essayait de
mettre la main mise sur la bulle réussie
d'aller voir les occidentaux pour
négocier etc et c'est ce qu'il y a c'est
qu'il est président depuis très très
longtemps et que la dernière fois qu'il
a été réélu entre guillemets en 2000 en
2020 ça s'est mal passé il y a eu des
manifestations
gigantesques aminsk et dans toute la
Biélorussie est très clairement le
régime de lucachenko aujourd'hui est
extrêmement affaibli et aujourd'hui la
situation a changé puisque Lucas and Co
dépend entièrement de Poutine c'est ça
qui est nouveau et donc pour le coup il
y a la la Biélorussie est complètement
rentrée dans l'orbite
de Moscou d'ailleurs il y a un
changement de la Constitution la
Biélorussie a abandonné son statut
diplomatique neutre elle a d'ailleurs
abandonné son statut de pays
dénucléarisé ce qui est évidemment
important pour pour la suite et donc
aujourd'hui c'est un allié à la fois
fidèle par défaut à Poutine et en même
temps extrêmement fragile
je ne suis pas sûr que que le cachenko
est intérêt à lancer son armée en
Ukraine parce que il y a déjà
suffisamment de problèmes en interne
néanmoins souviens que au début de
l'opération militaire russe donc le 24
février le il y avait eu un grand front
d'ailleurs le front principal à ce
moment là c'était le fond du Nord alors
c'était pas des soldats biéloruss mais
les soldats russes étaient passés par la
Biélorussie pour attaquer Kef par le
nord il est décédé le long des deux
rives du niep
et ensuite dans le j'avais perdu autour
de KEF c'était replié il était revenu
dans le domaine et depuis lors on
entendait plus trop parlé de la
Biélorussie
et sauf que là depuis ça fait quelques
semaines que ça commence à monter on a
entendu l'hypothèse que des troupes de
mobiliser russe pourraient s'entraîner
en Biélorussie et là donc ce matin dans
le dans ce contexte d'escalade militaire
parce que faut quand même dire ce qui
est c'est que depuis quelques semaines
on assiste à une escalade qui peut
encore une escalade nucléaire du merci
mais l'escalade pour la seconde
et bien lu cacher une CO a déclaré qu'il
y avait des menaces qui pesaient sur les
tabliers russe d'attaque venant alors il
a cité trois pays il a cité l'Ukraine la
Pologne et la Lituanie en disant il y a
des commandos qui infiltraient
pourraient menacer l'État biélorus et
donc il a annoncé la création d'un
groupement militaire commun
entre la Russie et la Biélorussie ce qui
veut dire en fait des troupes communes
qui qui interagiraient
mais sans préciser l'emplacement alors
c'est une on est clairement dans une
logique d'escalade encore une fois
conventionnel et donc il est très
probable que dans les jours semaine à
venir on verra des trouples Russes et
biélorusses se masser sur le sur le
front nord signal la frontière entre la
Biélorussie et l'Ukraine ce qui est de
la démonstration de force ça permet les
Ukrainiens sont obligés de
vous voyez des forces du Sud vers le
Nord donc c'est pas mes fixer des
Ukrainiens après toute la question et on
ne peut pas l'exclure complètement c'est
rationnellement il a probablement pas
intérêt à engager des forces parce que
déjà elles sont probablement pas
excellentes donc elles changeraient pas
la donne sur le terrain et en revanche
c'est un risque politique considérable
pour petit encore une fois si Poutine il
y a déjà beaucoup de problèmes à gérer
si en plus le le régime de loup cachenko
et profondément déstabilisé
ça sera ça commence à faire beaucoup ça
va faire beaucoup on a déjà vu que en
Asie centrale très clairement Poutine la
plus trop et un peu accaparée par
l'Ukraine donc il n'y a plus trop les
moyens de s'occuper de l'Arménie etc et
que donc les les conflits ont tendance
dans ce vide créé par l'opération
militaire spécial
ça revient si en plus il a géré la
Biélorussie il serait mal mais en même
temps on voit qu'on est dans une logique
de
d'escalade et de blocs contre blog donc
on ne peut pas l'exclure
même si ça peut paraître de l'extérieur
assez irrationnel donc ça ça sera à voir
dans les dans les mois prochains mais en
tendant on en attendons il fait monter
là la pression alors on a quel contrôle
qui nous demande une gagnant sur l'OTAN
il demande est-ce que l'aliment combien
il y a de soldats de l'OTAN qui sont à
la frontière orientale est-ce qu'on
est-ce qu'on sait ça je vais pas les
chiffres mais les ordres de grandeur ça
doit être quelques
dizaines de mille je compte de pardon je
parle de soldat
qui ne sont pas des pays limitrophes
parce que je veux dire
l'armée polonaise bon voilà mais
mais vous ayez en fait il y a pas besoin
d'avoir beaucoup puisque la doctrine
otanienne en la matière c'est il y a un
concept dont j'ai oublié le nom qui est
de dire que si on met plein de de de
soldats de plein de pays différents en
cas d'attaque tout le monde est attaqué
tout le monde est lié et donc en fait il
suffit d'avoir des petits effectifs pour
que ensuite ça concrétise en fait le
principe de l'article 5 qui est que
quand il y a une attaque bah tout le
monde tous les pays membres de l'OTAN
sont sont concernés on a Adam qui nous
demande de penser ou pas que la
stratégie russe est d'attendre l'hiver
et qui va me permettre de faire une
petite transition vers un petit article
qui a été publié ce week-end alors
écoute on sait hop à quelle heure mais
alors sans raconter tout ce qui est dans
Star c'est article pour pour
est-ce que la Russie peut se permettre
d'une stratégie d'attendre l'hiver c'est
très clairement ce qu'elle fait
déjà parce qu'elle a pas le choix parce
que maintenant
tout va dépendre de l'impact des forces
mobilisées sur le cours du conflit donc
ça prend plusieurs mois et donc ils vont
essayer de profiter de l'hiver pourquoi
profiter de l'hiver parce que en hiver
les flux logistiques sont encore plus
difficiles
et donc les manœuvres ne sont pas
facilités et donc ça défavorise plutôt
le celui qui est à l'initiative celui
qui est à l'offensive et donc en ce
moment c'est plutôt les Ukrainiens donc
ça devrait non pas arrêter mais ralentir
les opérations militaires et ça c'est
plutôt à la faveur de la de la Russie
sachant que l'autre aspect du général
hiver c'est pas un aspect militaire
c'est un aspect géopolitique géo
économique parce que qui dit hiver dit
froid dit froid dit énergie et donc quel
va être l'impact de l'inflation du prix
du gaz de l'électricité des pénuries de
la sobriété comme dit le gouvernement
sur les sur les esprits sur les opinions
publiques et à la fin peut-être sur les
sur les décisions des
Occidentaux effectivement alors j'ai
Eric qui me pose une question mais
j'étais pas très bien compris il se
passera quoi si l'Ukraine passe sur un
des quatre territoires qu'il occupe la
Russie est-ce que vous pouvez reformuler
cette question
répondu sur le sur le nucléaire
on a beaucoup de questions
en deux phrases on ne peut pas l'exclure
même si ça paraît pas extrêmement
extrêmement rationnel par rationnel
parce que quel serait l'intérêt
militaire qu'est-ce que ça changerait
sur le terrain donc employé une arme
nucléaire tactique c'est une arme qu'on
a pris sur le champ de bataille et qui
est plus petite que que enfin c'est déjà
gros mais ça peut être plusieurs fois
hiérarchique mais c'est on va dire sinon
une logique qu'on appelle antiforce
c'est à dire contre des forces
militaires et non pas dans une logique
contre cité circontre des centres
urbains sauf que là ça poserait beaucoup
de difficultés pour Poutine le soutien
occidental
augmenterait considérablement de alors
ça serait pas il y aurait pas de réponse
nucléaire symétrique puisque l'Ukraine
n'est pas protégé par l'article 5 de
l'OTAN et par le parapluie nucléaire
américain ou français ou britannique
mais il y aurait une notamment
probablement sur la question des
armements à longue portée dont on
parlait tout à l'heure et pour l'instant
les Occidentaux ne sont pas allés jusque
là deuxièmement les Chinois les Indiens
et on va dire tout le le sud qui
aujourd'hui ne soutient pas Poutine mais
ne le condamne pas s'abstituant et
regarde cette guerre comme si c'était
une guerre extérieure à cette partie du
monde là pour le coup
l'un de la Chine pourrait dire ouh là
non là c'est une frontière qui ne faut
pas franchir et donc Poutine pourrait
perdre malgré tout ce qui a un soutien
de la Chine notamment donc il y aurait
beaucoup de risques pour pour Poutine
maintenant Joe Biden a parlé
d'apocalypse nucléaire et il a évoqué un
parallèle avec la crise des missiles de
Cuba donc je rappelle 62 il y avait des
missiles soviétiques qui avaient été
installé à Cuba
donc en face pouvant frapper les
américains passent des Américains à 400
ou 300 km de la côte américaine ce qui
était complètement incroyable étant
donné la doctrine Monroe qui qui
sanctuarisait tout le continent
américain c'était un véritable choc mais
la grande différence justement entre la
crise des missiles de Cuba et
aujourd'hui c'est que la crise des
missiles du Cuba c'était de facto un
potentiel conflit nucléaire entre deux
puissances nucléaires là entre
guillemets il n'y a qu'une puissance
nucléaire c'est la Russie
et a priori il n'y aurait pas de réponse
symétrique en la matière oui donc
effectivement je pense que
il faut se méfier sur ces sujets là de
termes absolument fantasmagorique qui
renvoie une sorte d'Armageddon de de fin
du monde on n'en est pas du tout là
mais on ne peut pas exclure un usage
tactique de l'arme nucléaire qui a pris
la parole tout à l'heure Anafi le dit
Nadi ce n'est pas du bluff ce qu'il a
fait oui mais ça il le répète depuis le
24 février
il le répète depuis le 24 février
alors
Eric qui demandait je devrais que
va-t-il se passer si l'Ukraine arrive
sur un des quatre territoires que la
Russie a réussi à avoir dernièrement il
parle des référendums alors on va
remonter la carte c'est quoi la question
si l'Ukraine arrive à alors ce qui est
déjà lequel alors attendez on est la
carte on vous parce que il faut rappeler
que ils ont instauré des référendum dans
des zones qui ne contrôlaient pas
absolument surtout par exemple le
don-basse ou zapporigia je crois que
c'était autour de 60 les cas de régions
c'est Kerson dans l'ordre qui ressemble
il contrôle quasiment l'ougance mais
mais avec la contre-offensive du crédit
c'est même plus le cas il y a notamment
un village qui l'a échappe le Denis ils
ont énormément de mal à avancer c'est la
ville de makum dont on parlait tout à
l'heure et là il contrôle à dire 60%
zaporigial
la ligne de front est stable depuis
plusieurs mois mais combien de temps on
ne sait pas et que personne les Russes
reculent donc si vous voulez c'est déjà
le cas
alors
Andreï monde s'il a bien réussi attaque
aussi l'Ukraine alors pourquoi nous
pourrions pas aussi aider l'Ukraine
alors là aussi on est tendance on est
ronde on est quand même dans la gestion
on est déjà l'Ukraine oui déjà en plus
c'est sûr déjà massivement après si on
entend par là envoyer des troupes
régulières sur le seul ukrainien pour
l'instant on en est pas du tout là je
pense que les opinions publiques
d'ailleurs ne je dis pas que c'est une
impossibilité
j'ai pour l'instant dans le débat public
on n'est pas là alors Vladimir Poutine a
fait une première annonce ce matin ce
midi est-ce qu'il pourrait y en avoir
d'autres dans la dans la fin de journée
et si j'ai bien courrier il y a une
réunion du G7 qui va se tenir demain on
pourrait avoir d'autres réactions
internationales par rapport à ça c'est
probable alors n'oubliez pas il était
pour ses 70 ans pour son anniversaire il
était à Saint-Pétersbourg parce qu'il
est originaire de Saint-Pétersbourg
et donc hier il n'a pas quitté
Saint-Pétersbourg pour revenir à Moscou
malgré le
la taxe sur le pont de Kerch
et d'ailleurs ce matin il a fait son
discours pré-enregistré de
Saint-Pétersbourg donc là visiblement le
Conseil de sécurité
se tient dans la journée est-ce que il
va le faire en vidéo conférence ou
est-ce qu'il va revenir très rapidement
à Moscou je n'ai pas d'éléments de
réponse on va voir ce qui ce qui va
annoncer
en tout cas son discours de ce matin il
y avait rien de nouveau il y avait rien
de très inquiétant au sens il a rappelé
que c'était une réponse
mais il a bien
mis l'accent sur cette question là et le
fait que c'était un premier épisode et
que c'était au passé ils avaient réagi
et qui réagirait s'il y avait de
nouvelles attaques mais que là l'épisode
était
comme souvent donc le vice-président du
Conseil de sécurité ancien président
ancien Premier ministre lui a tenu des
propos beaucoup plus belliqueux mais
depuis le début il se partage les rôles
les rôles le premier épisode a été joué
il y en aura d'autres
j'avais d'autres questions voilà on a
donc une demande si la Russie radelle
les moyens d'armée tous ces mobilisés où
en est le stock d'armes russes est-ce
qu'on a eu moins de idée de ça
oui on a quelques idées la question
c'est pas ils auront des kalachnikov
pour chacun de ces hommes ça il y a pas
de il y a pas de doute c'est la question
est plus fine c'est quel équipement
dans quel état est-ce que il y a il y a
toutes les fonctions supports qui vont
avec est-ce que il y a les cadres est-ce
que il est sous-officiers les officiers
est-ce que l'état-major est capable
d'absorber une force aussi importante
est-ce qu'ils sont capables de manœuvrer
d'assurer la logistique de coordonner
tout ça et ça on a on n'a pas la réponse
à la question et sachant que si vous les
équipements
tendentiellement ce qu'on voit c'est que
si vous voulez c'est une pyramide donc
l'eau de la pyramide c'est les
équipements les plus modernes ça très
clairement les Russes en ont de moins en
moins et donc aujourd'hui on voit sur le
champ de bataille des chars t62m qui
sont
on en avait parlé l'autre fois c'est
c'est un char qui a
50 ans maintenant il y avait été mis en
service au début des années 60 un peu
comme si la France ressortait ses mx30
mais d'ailleurs la question se pose
aujourd'hui donc si vous voulez on
descend la pyramide et donc voilà ce
sont des armes de moins en moins moderne
ce qui est très intéressant avec les
missiles de croisière parce que là on
est 75000 c'est absolument considérable
mais ce qu'on observe depuis maintenant
deux mois c'est que les Russes utilisent
chaque jour de moins en moins de
missiles de précision et pourquoi parce
que le stock russe domicile de précision
et notamment vraiment le haut de la
pyramide dans la matière c'est le
missile qui est libre et les missiles il
scandeurs ils en ont de moins en moins
donc on voit de plus en plus de missiles
balistiques Toshka U qui sont nettement
plus anciens beaucoup plus imprécis ou
une portée de 180 km qui est beaucoup
moins beaucoup moins grande on voit
qu'il commence à utiliser des missiles
seul air donc des missiles dans le monde
ent les utilisent notamment des systèmes
S300 pour des frappes contre la terre où
ils utilisent des missiles anti navire
pour des frappes contre la terre tout ça
ça montre que les Russes sont commencent
à avoir des stocks à certains endroits
s'épuisent mais le même problème existe
que tu es ukrainien donc la guerre
d'usure qui va qui va la gagner on n'a
pas encore la réponse à cette question
et les drones iraniens rentrent aussi
dans ce
c'est une stratégie d'ailleurs assez
intelligente parce que un drone suicide
qui sert à frapper des objectifs fixes à
très longue distance
ça coûte
beaucoup beaucoup moins cher qu'un
missile ça coûte quelques dizaines de
milliers de dollars un missile ça se
compte en millions pour le
potentiellement le même résultat donc
voilà c'est chacun essaye de s'adapter
au contingences de la guerre au niveau
des de l'Occident il y a une réunion qui
devrait se tenir demain
avec les pays du G7 est-ce que il peut y
avoir des qu'est-ce qui peut être dit de
ce côté là est-ce que on va repartir sur
un nouveau train de sanction ou est-ce
que alors déjà on va condamner oui mais
ça on le fait déjà voilà très bien déjà
on va condamner le le
mot qui est utilisé depuis ce matin par
tous les dirigeants ces crimes de guerre
ça c'est intéressant parce que parce
qu'effectivement le
[Musique]
c'est que s'il y a des difficultés
énergétiques ukrainiennes durable oui
parce que ça aura un impact sur le sur
les les flux logistiques de l'armée
ukrainienne notamment parce que les
logistique dépend du train et que même
s'il y a des
locomotives diesel il y a encore tout un
système ferroviaire qui repose
principalement sur l'électricité donc si
vous n'avez plus d'électricité tout le
flux logistique est fragilisé ne
serait-ce qu'en termes de signalisation
ce qui fait que les trains doivent
rouler plus lentement et donc ce qu'il
faut observer maintenant les prochaines
semaines c'est est-ce que Poutine va
escalader à cet endroit là c'est le seul
endroit où il peut escalader c'est
est-ce qu'il va taper le réseau
ferroviaire est-ce qu'il va taper les
centres d'électricité est-ce qu'il va
taper les les routes etc c'est ce que
demandait les nationalistes russes
depuis des mois depuis il faut lire les
réseaux sociaux russes ils étaient
énervé par le fait que les Russes
par exemple n'avaient pas attaqué les
ponts qui traversent le Nieppe il y en a
beaucoup j'ai calculé il y en a 24 donc
il faudrait qu'il fasse tomber 24 ponts
pour bloquer l'Ukraine l'Ukraine en deux
mais c'est un discours qui monte depuis
des mois aussi à la droite de Poutine et
pour l'instant Poutine a été assez
frileux je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais au lendemain de la grande
offensive
ukrainienne à carquif déjà il y avait eu
des tirs de missiles
dans tout l'as de l'Ukraine il y avait
eu des coupures d'électricité pendant
plusieurs heures
si pendant quelques heures
quelques jours par mois il y a pas
d'électricité il y a des problèmes
d'électricité en Ukraine ça va pas
changer le cours de la guerre si en
revanche l'Ukraine est complètement
paralysé dans son système
d'infrastructure là ça peut changer le
cours de la guerre mais réellement
évaluer les la situation plutôt en
faveur des Russes mais on en est pas là
aujourd'hui il y en a contamine qui nous
demande juste est-ce que l'Occident a de
les moyens de relancer les négociations
de paix on n'est pas là non plus on
n'est pas là du tout c'est absolument
pas signe effectivement possible merci
beaucoup Alexis d'avoir été avec
aujourd'hui merci à vous d'avoir été
très nombreux à nous suivre la suite du
programme c'est à 17h vous avez
rendez-vous avec le buzz TV donc c'est à
17h et à 17h30 je te recevrai Sophie de
Ravinel autour de la question du jour
qui est après les polémiques cadenas et
Bayou pensez-vous que la nups va éclater
on parlera politique française et non
plus internationale merci encore Alexis
et à bientôt pour de nouveaux live sur
figure live